this is the end of august and the
beginning of a bunch of new releases
we're starting off with world of
warcraft legion the sixth expansion in
the popular series as expected they're
raising the level cap from 100 to 110
adding artifact weapons for each class
specializations adding a new area on
Azeroth called broken Isles and
introducing the demon hunter hero class
he starts at level 98 it will initially
include 10-5 man dungeons and two raids
they're going to keep you busy and you
head to those broken Isles on the 30th
next up if you enjoyed the manga or
animated series attack on Titan you're
probably interested in playing the game
that's been out for some time in Japan
it's coming to North America and Europe
this week so you can take down Titans by
yourself or with your friends in online
multiplayer mode you do pretty much what
you see in the anime taking down Titans
limb by limb and then cutting them at
their nape for the execution each
character has their own ultimate ability
from me causas ability to hit multiple
times in row 2 Aaron jaegers titan mode
prepare your eyes for some gory
cutscenes this game follows the anime
exactly and all those upsetting moments
yeah those ones you remember and it even
goes past the first season's so be
prepared for spoilers from the second
season from this very very upsetting
game and yes the Titans baby walks just
like you remember this is out on the
30th speaking of overseas we have to God
Eater games making their way to the
Americas this week God Eater
resurrection and God Eater to rage burst
these games are set in early 2050 where
life-forms called Oracle cells are
trying to consume all the life on Earth
they quickly evolved into monsters known
as origami and it's your job as an
origami hunter to take down those dudes
and save the world that's what makes you
of God
God Eater resurrection launches on the
twenty-eighth and God Eater to rage
burst launches on the thirtieth resident
evil 4 is in many ways the most
notorious game in the franchise maybe
because it started today's third person
shooter standards or maybe it was just
because of Lyon you can now relive or
enjoy for the first time in true HD
version it includes every single add on
that was released for the original game
including Ada Wong side story
mercenaries and new game+ never been a
better time to try resident evil 4
officially releases on August 30th and
will be priced at 20 bucks finally we're
getting a squad-based multiplayer
first-person shooter that's based in
world war one no not battlefield it's
Verdun it was released in 2015 on steam
but now it's coming to ps4 and Xbox one
you're going to infamous battles like
the Battle of Verdun that took place in
France in 1916 there's accurate world
war 1 weapons authentic uniforms and
equipment detailed injury and gore
modeling and maps based on the real
battlefields from the Western Front
there's up to 32 players in four game
modes frontlines attrition warfare squad
defense and the rifle deathmatch game
modes consider grabbing this on the 30th
and that's all I have for you this week
do you remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and sometimes
they change I'll see you next week
you